i heard that women wear red because
they put red on what what they want men
to notice
how interesting yeah so that's why a
woman would wear a red dress
and red
makeup
so like a woman to a man
red
you see red from anywhere
yes definitely
inciting
and you're more likely to wear red when
you're ovulating too
cute
i'm bleeding by the way i'm also red
but there's one thing that you there's
something that you refer to you fail to
understand the women's practice um self
objectification
where
the image that you portray is what we
see
so if you dress up in a way that
suggests that all you want is
sex that's what we see
yeah but they don't yeah but they'll
they'll convince themselves but you
you're going to say yeah i'm doing this
for myself
what do you mean by dress in a way that
says i'm wanting sex okay look at this
way for me i think the dating
dating is a gateway to three
marketplaces so you've got the section
marketplace the relationship marketplace
and the marriage marketplace so when the
woman dresses up as a guy at one look at
her in five seconds i can tell which of
those marketplace she wants me to
see
by just looking at the way she dress
and most men are like me
so how has that worked out for you so
far just like not in an offensive way
but how is that so you put these women
into these three categories um how has
that worked out for you so far are you
now in a you said you're single so how's
that putting them into those three
marketplaces by judging them by the way
that they've dressed as that worked out
for you well i used to be married i was
married for 20 years okay so when that
ended i decided okay forget marriage let
me just do this sexual marketplace thing
that was brilliant it was liberating and
all that but i then got to the point
where
i think you know women is too much
trouble
but it's true women even the nicest one
comes along and because i'm a nice guy a
girl told me that i'm too nice and
because of that i'm vulnerable
and she's trying to take advantage of me
so i'm saying okay fine i will come and
find you when i need you you can't you
can't shame him by like implying like
that as personal life because that's
kind of what you're doing i'll tell you
but what i'm saying but i'm saying like
because that's how men are is they they
categorize women by like the way you
present yourself
yeah like the same way girls will
categorize men by the way they if they
look like a bummer they're wearing a
suit
and there's another thing that you don't
realize when you spend three hours doing
yourself up and you come out
it's from my point of view it's good for
your mental health if i look at you and
make comments because otherwise that
would be a waste of three hours of your
life if i don't see anything it's polite
yeah i don't think so do you know what i
don't think so that's how it works so i
see you're thinking oh she spent so much
time let me give her a compliment you
look nice even if i don't want anything
with you
yeah like because if if a girl is
dressing in a way that's seeking
attention how could she be mad when she
gets it
so if you're if you're dressing in a way
where your ass is out your boobs are out
you're a full face of makeup and then
someone compliments you you're mad
i don't get compliments when i go out in
my sweats
like
so we can't change the outcome for our
actions that's the thing if we do
something people are going to perceive
it one way or another but i think a lot
of yeah i think that i tend to think
that
you know you shouldn't just because i'm
dressed the same way doesn't mean that's
who i am and that might be true but the
thing is people
judge by the first few seconds of what
they see especially men when it comes to
deciding is this
do i see this person as a wife to me or
do i see
um this person as somebody who might be
good for a hookup or whatever people but
what women don't realize is you think a
man thinks like you so you then think
okay i want to be a wife and then you're
dressed like a slot and the one's
looking at you i'm thinking oh this is a
slot
and most men will not be honest enough
to tell you that
yeah the truth is there's a saying right
clothing is a dress of thought you can
tell a lot about someone by
how they wear their clothes the kind of
clothes they wear so and i think women
understand this women
dude women understand women are
extremely women know this stuff very
very well i think women like talk to
each other and they're like
could i convince this guy that this guy
is actually green
like if i convinced
that i wore this g-string just because i
like g-strings i did it for me
i wore a thong bikini for myself
they're so comfortable though you get
like less tan lines
[Laughter]
why do you want that big white patch all
the way across your bum
do you know what i mean so
what the same for men
because i remember i got stopped by the
police and they probably said to me do
you know what i would stop you i said no
and they gave me this [ __ ] about
your car's got no mit
and i'm dressed in [ __ ] on trousers
then they stop another black guy it came
out it's got his jeans on his pants
showing oh that's my brother and the way
they treated him um i would literally
stand inside each other the way they
treated him was completely different
they treated me with respect
they throw his car away they find two
thoughts on my car and they gave me an
option which i found strange they said
you got an option i said what's that
said three points or you go and change
your tire
i don't think are you serious he said
yeah so i went i said i'll change the
tire
they didn't give the boy they didn't
give me any option at all they found one
foot in this car they brought the tow
truck and took it away
and it didn't didn't see anything it
wasn't rude it was just the way you
dressed
do you think do you not judge people at
all by the way they're dressed
so if if a dude comes in a very nice
expensive suit you don't assume he has a
better job than a homeless man on the
street i mean the assumption on the like
on the job front yeah i get it right i
get that like maybe this person's so you
can make assumptions such as like maybe
they have more money or maybe you don't
think a girl that wears less clothes and
posts her ass on the internet has a
higher need for attention than someone
who doesn't
you know that everyone's needy though
like if you're online posting pictures
you're needy anyway so so could you
answer the question yeah yes or no
do you think a girl that posts your ass
on the internet
needs more attention than someone who
doesn't
depends what
yes or no yes or no
yes or no you can you could say yes and
then explain or know and then explain
okay um
no and i'll explain okay right because
you can
i feel like you can know yourself
i'm not saying i don't know how to like
word it
you can know yourself
and
depend it depends what you use your
social media for right
that's the way i'm going about it
because if you're just if you're just
like an average person and you're just
you're just randomly taking pictures of
yourself naked and then posting them on
instagram then yeah i would say that is
for attention okay but if you're like i
don't know if you're if you've got a
swimsuit collection
and you've got a business
then
i don't think you you could have a model
do that just have to be you
you could just pay someone to do it or
there's a there's a lot of it it would
still be someone that's naked on your
instagram though yeah but it wouldn't be
be you yeah
so you still stand by the no
she's just trying to dance around the
corner
i want to say it's 50 50.
what percent what percent of women do
you think own a swimsuit collection
everyone
oh wait a swimsuit collection
out of a hundred women how many owners
from school actually said just out of a
hundred women how many own a swimsuit
collection like probably like one okay
so why why are you standing on the 50 50
then because i just don't think that
like why do you post pictures of
yourself when you're at the beach you
want to like for attention like why
would you post any you could send a
picture to the people you want to send
it to like your friends and family why
do anything on the internet you know i
think it'd be weirder from one of my
friends sent text me a picture of her at
the beach than if i saw it online but
i'm saying it's for attention regardless
it's for attention from someone you
could just take the pictures to have
other like why would you post it if you
didn't want other people to see it and
get attention from it yeah okay i think
what the issue is is that it's become a
culture so when you've been doing
something for so long you forget the
reason why you're doing it
until you actually reflect and think
deeply oh you're questioned like how you
are right now but
do you know what like i think going back
to what you said you you're saying
there's something so bizarre about men
that will randomly say things to you as
you're walking through the street all
the time yeah but why it depends on what
you say why because it's like it's not
warranted like if i'm literally
sometimes drank came up to you on the
street
i don't fancy drake like that sorry
who's someone you fancy you get that you
get what i'm trying to know what you're
trying to say but like liz like listen
to what i'm saying right
so if i'm like every day i'm like rush
it like i'm person
don't want to say i'm late on the
internet [ __ ] it
every day i'm like speed walking to the
tube right
like at a solid pace so it doesn't look
like i want to talk to anyone it doesn't
look like i'm trying to grab the
attention of anyone i'm not like swaying
do you know what i mean i'm i'm going
somewhere and there is always someone
that's like hello
oh babes uh and you're just like why
like why it sounds so horrible i can't
imagine like what that's like
something like this you like that do you
like i don't know i just don't care
i don't like just to be if someone if
someone if someone complains if someone
compliments me like why would i get
offended they're complimenting you just
say take the compliment and go
like i just feel like you're going out
of your way to get offended
why'd you like why like
you're wasting your energy it's just
like okay thanks and then you keep going
even if even if he's creepy it's like
they're calling they're saying something
nice to you it's a thing to do as well
they're just shooting their shot
honestly